[Music]
you can be invincible
if you never enter a contest in which
victory is not under your control
beware lest when you see some person
preferred to you in honor
or possessing great power or otherwise
enjoying high repute
you are ever carried away by the
external impression
and deem him happy for if the true
nature of the good is one of the things
that are under our control
there is no place for either envy or
jealousy
and you yourself will not wish to be a
prater or a senator
or a consul but a free man now there
is but one way that leads to this and
that is to despise the things that are
not
under our control
chapter 19 begins with this observation
by epictetus about what it would require
for us to be invincible that is
unconquerable
or in the greek nikkeitos nikkei means
victory
and one of the
common drives that we have as human
beings
is what the greeks called philo nikia
meaning the desire to
to win the desire to beat out the others
in competition
it often turns into a desire to be right
to have others acknowledge that is the
case
and so all of this is is tied up in this
conception of being
invincible really the invincibility that
we should be
most concerned with has to do with our
self
and our judgment about our self a
realistic judgment
not an inflated judgment that we're
something that we're not
not a narcissistic judgment also not a
depressive or
you know self-destructive judgment that
that says that we're worse off than we
are
so what does it take to be unconquerable
so one way to do this and this is can be
understood in multiple
ways he says you can be invincible if
you never
enter a contest in which victory is not
under your control
and so when you hear that at first it
might be
tempting to believe that the stoic is
saying
all right withdraw from life all
together
never take any risks just maintain
yourself
in as as you know controlled
and as invulnerable a posture as you
possibly can
don't let anybody hurt and here we can
think about what what might get hurt
don't let anybody hurt your body right
don't place yourself in risky situations
which is a good idea
prudence dictates that anyway but your
body
is not really what he's talking about in
in other places epictetus will
acknowledge
that when it comes to disease when it
comes to the things that other people
might do to our body
when it comes to famine and hunger even
when it comes to bodily death
these are things that largely lie
outside of our control if they lie in
anybody's control
they lie in somebody else's control it's
their thoughts their decisions their
actions
that decide that we're going to get hurt
epictetus when he was a slave
he he was lamed by his owner so the
story goes
and the owner was messing around with
his leg and epictetus said if you keep
pushing it
you're going to ruin it and the owner
did that
and ended up making him lame as a result
that's a perfect example of something
where it's impossible for us to make
ourselves
invincible we can't make ourselves
bodily invincible
nor can we do so when it comes to our
possessions we can
you know invest in security we can
make sure that we know the local police
we can be part of the neighborhood watch
we can find out who the local criminals
are and buy them off we can do all sorts
of things
we could even you know worry about uh
the government taxing us and so we're
trying to hide our wealth
none of that really provides us with the
kind of invincibility
the the in the the state of not being
able to be
conquered or bested that he's talking
about here
so what else we could talk about our
reputations there it's something even
more ephemeral
uh our online presence uh all it takes
you know is somebody to hack into your
account
post a few things that are offensive and
everything that you've got could be
destroyed in an instant
or yeah you could do that yourself you
know without the hacking
or somebody parodies you and suddenly
everybody's laughing at you right
all these things are ways in which we
are the opposite of
invincible so what does it mean then
to only enter a contest where victory is
under our control
it means that when we're engaged in some
sort of contest about
what matters it should be with ourselves
it should be over whether we can
discipline ourselves whether we can
reorient our choices
so that we in fact pursue the right
things
so that we use the appearances that we
have rightly
so that we use our bodies rightly so
that we use our relationships rightly or
approach our relationships rightly
so that we fulfill our roles and duties
and obligations
the way that justice requires us to do
so that we
build the virtues within ourselves and
gradually
rip out or exterporate and that's what
extrapolate really means
the vices within ourselves so that we
move from
cowardice to courage we move from folly
to wisdom
we move from injustice or unfairness or
greed or whatever other modality of it
you want to
justice and that we move from a lack of
self-control
over bodily desires and appetites
to the state that the ancients called
temperance or
moderation all of that is a victory
all of that is something where we can be
defeated
but the only thing that can really
defeat us
isn't those things on the outside if you
act intemperately
and you eat the third helping at dinner
and then have dessert
after that it wasn't the food that made
you do that
the food you know presented itself as an
appearance to you saying
you're gonna love this come on over here
and get it
but you and your desires
directed yourself that way and you could
have
resisted if you had you know some stoic
dogmata ready at hand and you decided i
want to think this decision out in terms
of my larger
goal of having my faculty of choice
in accordance with nature in terms of
developing and deploying the virtues so
all of that is just commentary on the
first sentence let's go on and
look at the examples that he has these
are examples that were common in
epictetus's time in culture
they're very common in ancient cultures
all across the board cross
you know across civil civilizationally
and they are just as common in our own
time
probably because they're part of the
human condition that we're going to see
over and over again
so he says beware so that when you see
some person preferred to you in honor or
possessing great power
or otherwise enjoying high repute
you are ever carried away by the
external impression and deem him happy
watch out because otherwise this is sort
of an automatic process
our culture pushes this on to us
we actually have like a whole culture
industry as it's been called for now
decades
that um you know tells us these people
are happy these people are fortunate
these people are
we don't use the word blessed although a
few of them do every once in a while
uh but that's that's the the the tenor
of it
so we see people on on television shows
uh and we say oh my gosh what a great
life they're having
we forget that it's been so edited that
we're only seeing this tiny little
portion
and we can't see inside of the person
even if they do
like in reality shows go into the booth
and talk into the camera like i'm
i'm doing to you today right although
this isn't a booth this is my
my classroom
we have to watch out otherwise our
natural
tendencies given our culture and this is
not
nature in the way that we want it to be
the realized nature
nature rather in the sense of just how
things tend to pan out
our tendencies are to mistakenly assume
that these people are happy why are they
happy well like you said
somebody who is being preferred to you
in honor uh the greek for that is
right uh or somebody who has a lot of
power
um somebody who is mega do nominee
or uh somebody who is
enjoying high repute udoki
munta right and he says don't believe
that these people are
actually happy although the greek term
there is macaries which means blessed
it's a
state beyond mere eudaimonia in a lot of
philosophers
and it means to like be enjoying
everything bliss
this is something that a lot of people
think and this is what
we see you know leading people on if i
could just get
that next rung in the hierarchy i'm
gonna be so happy
if i could just you know have a youtube
channel with a hundred thousand viewers
instead of you know a thousand viewers
then i'll be
somebody this is how we often say it
i'll be somebody if i could just have a
hit
single right if i could just have that
big house
like the person who i admire has if i
could just have
the spending power that they do if i
could eat in the kinds of restaurants
that they do
if i could have the kind of uh
girlfriend or boyfriend or spouse
that it seems like the beautiful people
have and we could go on and on and on
and on
so what are we supposed to do he says
don't get carried away by the external
impression
we have flooding towards us all the time
appearances fantasia and they
tell us stories about how happy those
people are
about how wonderful it is to enjoy these
external goods
so he says if the true nature of the
good
is one of the things that are under our
control
then there is no place for either envy
or jealousy and
the terms that he's translating there
are thonos envy
and zelotoupia for for jealousy
and a little bit more about this zelos
can also mean something like emulation
you know when you
see somebody for example um let's say
you're a musician
and you go to a show and you see
somebody a great example from myself
i've seen bella fleck play
bella fleck is an amazing banjo player
and he's not just able to do you know
blue grassy kind of
traditional banjo stuff he plays the
entire gamut he can play classical music
he can play rock and roll
he can play you know whatever you want
uh he is a virtuoso
and i've gone to see him at the show and
i felt that that pain
that that sort of desire to be like him
i play banjo but you know at a very low
level nothing
remotely like what what he can do and
aristotle for example says zelos is a
good thing it drives us to try to be
better
it's a sign of good character but it can
easily turn into something
that um you know makes us feel bad
that uh you know drives us in
in certain ways and we want to be free
of that according to epictetus and the
stoics
so he says if the the you know what's
really good for us
is what's in our control what's within
us
then when you see the rich famous person
who's also uh you know
just killing it as we say right uh in so
many different ways um
are they actually enjoying that well you
don't really know
the things that they are enjoying aren't
the sorts of
goods that we ought to be
jealous or envious of it doesn't really
make sense from a stoic perspective
they're not even really goods from a
stoic perspective
but even if you assume that they are
because you know we often fall into
those
those uh assumptions
it's not something that we should
begrudge another
so if somebody else gets the position
you know then should i say uh oh
i should have gotten that position i
should be in that role
no it's it worked out that way there's
nothing for me to be envious of
in in that case so he goes on and he
says
you yourself will not wish if you
confine yourself to what's under your
control to be a prator
or a senator or a council these are all
sort of like high
titles like being president we might
think of being you know the ceo
or you know even lower level the office
manager right
if you're focused on what is within your
control
and you're finding your good there
you're not going to be
upset by the fact that you're not
getting promoted the way that you
think that you ought to or or other
people whispering in your ear
think that that you ought to uh instead
you will want to be a free person that
will be the focus and
eleutheros this uh this is translated
sometimes as a free person sometimes as
a liberal person
it means a person who actually gets to
decide for him or herself
and he goes on and he says now there is
but one way that leads to this
and that is to despise the things that
are not under our control
despise doesn't mean to hate the greek
term for it here
is cataphronein which means literally to
to look
down upon so it's not to look down upon
by tilting your head back like this
it's to realize that those things really
that are not under your control
like uh you know power prestige position
celebrity uh lots of money in the bank
all these these sorts of matters they're
not under your control
and you you don't have to say oh i hate
them that would really just be
being you know enthralled to them as
well you said they they
aren't that important they don't matter
that much that's what it is to
look down upon them or as he's saying
here to despise
bear them mind that it is not the man
who reviles or strikes you that
insults you but it is your judgment that
these men are insulting you
therefore when someone irritates you be
assured
that it is your own opinion which has
irritated you
and so make it your first endeavor not
to be carried away by the external
impression
for if once you gain time and delay you
will more easily become master of
yourself
chapter 20 is providing us with a
you might say very basic point in stoic
psychology
and in stoic ethics he says bear in mind
remember literally that it is not the
man
who reviles or strikes you that
insults you but it is your judgment
that these men are insulting you so
what is he saying there this is well
worth lingering over
um so to begin with the the greek term
that's you know strike
reviling you or striking you uh loiduron
uh to speak in an abusive way
to somebody else you know hey jerk you
know i'm not gonna
actually swear on this in the commentary
thing you could supply whatever you want
um telling jokes about you picking on
you all these
these sorts of things criticizing you
unfairly would be an example of that
um striking you to tone that that just
literally means to whack somebody right
um and now the term that he's using here
for insult is
and this this is a term that has a lot
of resonance in in greek
it can mean insulting it can mean
doing you know wanton uh injury to
somebody it has a wide
spectrum and we feel ourselves
oppressed in this way an awful lot
sometimes by people who
didn't even mean to do it sometimes
and this you know is going to strike us
as kind of crazy when we put it this way
uh by people who are half the world
around
from us and have never met us and
probably never will meet us but who we
see
on a video or we uh read you know the
the column that they wrote
in i don't know the new york times or
the london times or the bangladeshi
times whatever it
happens to be and we think that somehow
we are being offended that would be
another way
to translate um hubris in not
not so much with the connotation of the
the you know state of feeling offense
but somebody deliberately trying to
offend you
so we are in an environment where this
is a particularly big risk not
not you know only because we have the
enviro the the
internet as an integral part of our
environment
but in large part because of that but
also because of the fact that we
interact
personally and talk about the internet
so much as well
you could say the internet is flooded
over into our culture and it's very
difficult to get away from it
so what that's done is opened up a
greater exposure
for most people to being
in situations where they're confronted
with
other people saying things doing things
that that seem like
they have to do with with us um
if somebody for example starts you know
ranting about white
privilege well i'm white so probably
that has to do with me
even though that person has never met me
has no idea about what my circumstances
are you know it's not directed
at me but i can take it as personal
somebody cuts me off in traffic another
prosaic
example as well this is a great you know
great example for our modern times
whether you bike whether you drive a car
whether you take public transportation
there's always somebody in your way
and there's always somebody who's
working at cross purposes
to you is isn't there and so it's easy
to
see what they're doing as somehow
offending you
if somebody talks you know in a
disparaging way
about something that you care about it's
hard not to take that
personally and epictetus says look
remember
that what's going on is not that they're
actually
insulting you not even even though they
may in fact be trying to insult you
but um what's really going on is your
judgment your judgment is playing a
major role
in deciding what's going on your
judgment that these people
are insulting you is what
is a central cause if you can eliminate
that judgment
they can do whatever the hell they want
and it's got nothing to do with you
or you know if if you're an object of
the sentence
that guy over there dr sadler's a jerk
he you know
i don't like the way he teaches
philosophy i get i get comments like
this all the time
uh fortunately i get a lot better
comments more of the time
but sometimes you know he talks too fast
he talks too slow
you can't please everybody right um if i
if i judge that i am being
insulted by that person then i am
insulted by that person if i don't
engage in that judgment
then i am free from that and what is the
the judgment here
a dogma you know what we translate
as a judgment but we can also translate
as an opinion we can translate
as something that we say to ourselves or
something that we believe with
the sense of dogma so if i if i have in
the back of my head
all these dogmata that's the plural for
dogma kind of floating around
just you know waiting to be attached to
things i'm probably going to be a
miserable person when i go out into
traffic
or when i read through the comment
section on any given video
so he says when someone irritates you
be assured that it's your own opinion
which has irritated you
that's not to say that they might not
have had the intention of trying to
irritate you sometimes people
really you know do go around and try to
hurt each other
try to provoke a reaction for various
you know some people try to do that just
to make a lot of money because they know
that
what we call click bait the best
motivator is actually anger and you get
angry once you feel like somebody
has insulted or outraged you somebody
has committed hubris
right and he says but it's your opinion
that has actually
irritated you so and here he uses the
term
hoopolapsis your assumption would be
another way
of translating it so he goes on and he
says
make it your first endeavor not to be
carried away
by your external impression by the
appearance
don't let it grab on to you and pull you
around that's what the
the um being carried away is soon
arpas face and i right which
heart you know heart pain to grab onto
soon you sort of like it's grabbing all
around you
and pulling you in right so
don't allow your your uh opinion to do
that to you don't allow the appearances
to sweep over you and dominate you and
he says
if once you gain time and delay you will
more easily
become master of yourself so here's a
very useful
bit of advice we're confronted with
appearances
somebody is in a bar and they're you
know they slosh their drink on you
and then they turn around they say hey
jerk off you know look what you did you
made me spill my drink
uh what what's wrong with you right
you can react right away in which case
your reaction is probably going to be
something like hey you're the jerk off
buddy
or you know let's say you're adopting
the stoic thing and you kick in right
away hey i don't want any trouble buddy
you know um or you could just pause
you don't have to respond to everything
immediately this is another one of the
dangers that we
we often feel uh you know we feel that
we have to respond to things immediately
or
we're not taking charge of the situation
we're becoming passive
things are just happening to us
the people will keep on doing the same
thing to us
and that's not necessarily the case that
that right
right there is a dogma that is a
judgment that is something that we're
we're bringing to the situation instead
we can give ourselves a little bit of a
pause and then we can see whether the
appearance
really is the way it's presenting itself
or whether
we're projecting things into the
situation assumptions hoople
says or judgments opinions dogmata
if we're doing that and we notice
ourselves doing that we can pull those
back we can say i don't need to assume
this
now we probably don't need to go into
this whole process
explicitly with the person who seems to
be insulting us because that would
you know confuse them or provoke them
we can do this on our own and by doing
so we will
free ourselves up in some very
significant ways
you